et vous êtes mieux placé que quiconque
pour savoir que en politique
chaque jour est utile que chaque jour
compte et nous utiliserons par
conséquent tout séjour
tous ces mois que nous avons devant nous
pour donner de la force à la république
donner de la force à la france pour lui
permettre d'affronter les défis qu'elle
a devant elle
il faudra continuer à protéger protéger
le pays contre la menace terroriste on
nous n'avons cessé de dire vous même le
président de la république moi même
lorsque j'étais ministre de l'intérieur
quel état à niveau extrêmement élevé qui
implique que nous continuons à rehausser
comme vous l'avez fait comme nous
l'avons fait ensemble au cours des
derniers mois les moyens des forces de
sécurité intérieure et des services de
renseignements mais la protection
c'est aussi la protection à laquelle les
français sont attachés qui est celle de
notre modèle social la protection
sociale qui suppose que nous renforcions
aussi les efforts qui ont été engagés
pour maintenir l'équilibré de nos
comptes et garantir la pré pérennité de
notre modèle social français il y à la
nécessité de progresser aussi parce que
l'action publique ce sont chaque jour
des progrès qu'ont accompli des progrès
en europe où il ya encore beaucoup de
politiques qui appellent des initiatives
de la part de la france je pense à tout
ce qui relève du défi migratoire sur
lequel nous avons beaucoup travaillé
ensemble je pense à calais mais pas
seulement et qui justifie qu au sein de
l'union européenne nous puissions
poursuivre le renforcement des
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne et dans le souci de la
protection que l'on doit tous ceux qui
sont persécutés pour suivre aussi les
politique de relocalisation et les
politiques
développement de co développement à
destination des pays de provenance d'un
certain nombre d'hommes ces deux femmes
qui sont confrontés à une misère extrême
et puis nous avons aussi à préparer
l'avenir vous avez lancé avec le
président de la république beaucoup de
chantiers dans le domaine de la
recherche dans le domaine de
l'innovation dans le domaine du
développement durable vous avez évoqué
ce cas était l'extraordinaire réussite
de la coop 21 qui met la france en
première ligne en situation de devoir
aussi donc protégée progressé préparer
l'avenir
voilà ce que je vais essayer de faire
modestement dans la responsabilité que
le président de la république m'a fait
l'honneur de me confier dans la
continuité de ce que vous avez fait vous
même et avec monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls une seule boussole
qui est celle qui m'a guidé tout au long
de mon parcours ministériel et qui donne
de la force
lorsque l'essentiel est en jeu cette
boussole porte un nom le sens de l'état
je forme pour vous tous les voeux et je
veux vous dire mon indéfectible amitié
mon profond respect et ma très grande
reconnaissance pour la manière dont nous
avons travaillé ensemble au cours des
derniers mois et cela porte un nom dans
la vie politique et croyez-moi ça existe
l'amitié
[Applaudissements]